hey guys it's Justine I am so excited
because in front of me are two brand new
aura rings now if you are new here you
may not know that this has been my most
favorite piece of tech over the past
year I have been wearing one of these
every single day since August of last
year there have been a few nights where
I haven't worn it but pretty much for
the most part every single night this
has been on my hand tracking my sleep
tracking my workouts tracking every bit
of things happening with my body and I
love having this data so much it really
has changed the way that I look at sleep
the way that I look at Food timings of
workouts timing of when I'm eating also
me becoming very judgmental of my
friends if I want them to have a good
night's sleep they probably shouldn't be
drinking alcohol late at night I let
them know for sure I'm that friend I did
a video on the previous version if you
guys want to check that full video out
and review I'll put a link in the
description but today they have a new
design launching this is the aura ring
Horizon this is the New Aura ring
Horizon with all of the Gen 3 Aura ring
technology like sleep tracking blood
oxygen sensing and activity tracking
with a huge focus on sleep the oral ring
is able to accurately track when you are
in deep REM and light sleep letting you
know if you're getting enough of each it
does this by monitoring the nighttime
changes in your resting heart rate your
heart rate variability body temperature
and more now every morning my daily
routine is to check my ring when I wake
up it'll give you three daily scores
your sleep Readiness and activity and it
will also give you insights on how your
body is doing in some ways that you may
be able to improve it also has super
accurate prediction for your menstrual
cycle using research grade temperature
sensors usually a few days before I'll
get a notification that says it's
supposed to start in the next few days
and it has been spot on every single
time so here I am wearing the Gen 3.
this is the Silver version I do have a
few different colors I even have the
Gucci one which is absolutely beautiful
so you can see this has like a flat top
so it has kind of like a little circular
design with that flat little top and
that kind of lets you know the
orientation to wear your ring so the
temperature sensors are here in the Box
bottom there's a 3D accelerometer so
it's able to not only track your sleep
but it's also able to track your Fitness
but one of my favorite things is the
precise accuracy that this detects that
I'm taking a nap and I take a lot of
naps I live for naps I am a nap Queen if
you will and the fact that it's able to
detect that so quickly it's like oh you
nap for 46 minutes oh you've napped for
a lot longer like maybe like the two
hours and 45 minutes it's fine it's it's
a thing you know what happens I
sometimes have a weird sleep schedule
but for the most part I do try to get to
bed by 10 and I usually wake up between
5 50 and 6 30 most days this is too much
info because we need to just open these
so I can show you the brand new rings
and one of the things that I'm most
looking forward to is they now have a
rose gold ring and most of my jewelry is
all Rose okay well that is not gold I
forgot that I have upgraded to the Apple
watch Ultra but my previous watch was
gold and it looked so beautiful together
I am wearing the silver one because I
wanted to demo the different colors
normally gold is my aesthetic let's open
the rose gold one first because I've
been looking forward to this for a very
long time
this one is a perfect
circular ring and the difference is it
has a small little indentation right
here and that's to let you know where
the bottom of the ring is because you
want to wear the sensors close to the
palm of your hand so this gives you kind
of a tactile feel so if you're a
fidgeter like me you can make sure that
you keep that bottom little Ridge
decoration indentation at the palm of
your hand like look at the rose gold oh
my goodness it's so pretty I'm so into
it I cannot wait to just go to sleep
tonight so inside of the box also comes
with a charger and these are size
compatible so if you are wearing a
different size ring than your friend or
partner and you try to share these it
won't work because they are sized for
whatever ring that you have and if you
do order one of these they send you a
sizing kit so you'll be able to figure
out what size ring you need and most of
the time I do wear mine on my index
finger but sometimes when I am hiking my
fingers tend to swell so I will swap
this over to my ring finger and
depending upon you know what rings I
decide to look for I do kind of mix and
match them but for the most part the
most accurate is wearing it on your
index finger also comes with a USB
charger this is USBC as well I like this
little wheel that they have this cord
wrapped around that's a nice little
design a lot of times I just use my iPad
charger or even my MacBook charger but I
always carry an extra one of these with
me when I'm traveling just in case so
here is the differences between the two
this is the older gen 3 which has that
flat top design and this is the New
Horizon which has the little indentation
there and they both look really great
I'm so happy that they have a rose gold
option this is beautiful and we also
have a Gold version so I can show you
guys what that looks like so it does
come in five colors it comes in the four
original colors are gold black the
stealth and the silver and of course our
fifth being the brand new rose gold so
excited about this I can't believe it
take a look at the gold one it is the
same ring
but gold
with a little indentation which we're
going to flip to the bottom because
that's where it belongs oh of course
shall we shall we I don't think this
will fit on this finger oh it does okay
great now I'm going to show you the app
because this is where it's so powerful
the things that this can track the way
that it is able to give you
notifications and it's actually telling
me right now the need to charge my Gucci
Aura ring which is fantastic because now
we're going to be switching out to the
beautiful rose gold hello who is she one
of the things that I do like is how long
this battery life does last because this
isn't something that you do need to
charge every single day it has a super
fast charge I think you can make it
almost a week on one charge so a lot of
times what I'll do is I will have a
charger right by the shower in the
bathroom so I will just charge this
every morning when I get a shower and
that 30 minutes gives me enough time so
I never feel like I have to actually
ever really have it off for long because
I'm always doing sort of these little
incremental charges this is something
new that I like they have fit your goal
to your lifestyle so you can tap into
the activity card to adjust your
Baseline depending upon what you're
trying to achieve my activity goals at
300 my daily average calorie burn from
the last 30 days is 457 so you can set
that depending upon your activity level
or whatever it is that you're trying to
achieve now this does have the ability
to record live heart rate data so if you
are doing a workout so you can go in
here and you can choose which activity
you're doing and this is very accurate
also whenever it detects you doing an
activity so there'll be times that a
little notification will pop up and
it'll say you have an unconfirmed
activity from yesterday and I will go
and look and I'm like oh I actually was
walking the dog you can also go in and
add a previous activity so a lot of
times I won't wear this when I'm doing
any martial arts class because I don't
want to injure my training partner so I
will take it off for that so I'm not
able to record that but the record
workout HR is a newer feature that came
in the Gen 3 so you are able to work out
with just this and it'll still be able
to record that live heart rate data so
here are my activities from today I did
some light strength training and I did
some cycling so I did a 30 minute cycle
resting heart rate for the last eight
weeks my Readiness level the sleep is
where it's very interesting because when
you go into here this will show you your
time awake your REM your light and your
deep sleep and I woke up at 3am for some
reason and I had to go to the bathroom
and then I could not fall back asleep so
you can see in between that time I was
pretty much wide awake and then I do
normally naturally wake up around 5 50
to 6 a.m but today as I'm recording this
it was a Sunday so I'm like I'm gonna
just treat myself and sleep in maybe a
little bit longer so I slept for another
about an hour until 707 am when one of
my many iPhone alarms went off somewhere
in the house and I had to find it so
that was fun so when I go into my sleep
let's go and find oh look at this my ore
review total number of naps steps walked
and more so this is going to give me a
look back at the last three months I
earned 127 crowns I took a total of 27
naps
who is she my longest night of sleep
happened on Sunday April 10th 9 hours
and 21 minutes
dude what happened on April 9th is what
I'm curious about average sleep per
night 6 hours 49 minutes your best
average nighttime heart rate comeback
happened on Monday June 13th oh my
goodness tell us more this quarter was
definitely one to remember
wow I like that it gives you that little
update that's pretty cool this gives you
your total sleep your efficiency your
restfulness your REM sleep your deep
sleep your latency and these all will
kind of change depending on how well or
how terrible you have slept and these
will give you things that you can do to
make it better so when you click into
the restfulness this will give you some
options of things you can do like
optimize your sleep environment avoid
spicy heavy meals and alcohol close to
bedtime try to complete your workouts at
least one or two hours before bed and
help your body wind down by avoiding
bright blue lights one to two hours
before going to sleep I'm not good at
that because I like to scroll on Tick
Tock before going to my Slumber now when
we go into the Readiness I love this
this is one of my favorites because this
is where you can go in and see your body
temperature so this will give you your
different Trends so as we see these
Trends this is something really
fascinating that I didn't even know for
the longest time is that when it's time
for your period your body temperature
actually drops so everyone with a period
this is some very helpful knowledge I
can't believe I didn't know about until
last year so you can see the trends here
high body temperature and then as it
drops then that's when the time of the
month happens fun we're loving that
aren't we no we're not and this is the
main screen that you're greeted with so
you can also go in and see your heart
rate so you can see your restorative
time your sleeping heart rate and then
if you did any workouts that you
recorded they would go right here and
then you have your daytime lowest
average heart rate as well so you'll see
your daytime heart rate ratings when you
wear your ring throughout the day which
I almost always do
do you know
thank you guys so much for watching I'm
gonna put a link in the description
where you can check out the brand new
Aura Horizon ring and if you want you
can check out some of the other rings
that they have to offer I'm so excited
they have the New Aura ring in rose gold
it's so beautiful thanks again for
watching if you haven't already be sure
to subscribe hit the Bell to be notified
when I post new videos and make sure you
check out my full Aura ring gen 3 review
if you haven't seen it already I'll see
you guys in the next video bye
perfect
[Music]